[Music]  Kim Kardashian looking you know white  hot this week I want to wear things that  make me feel good about myself the 37  year old was snapped leaving the bel-air  restaurant on Wednesday after enjoying  dinner with pals but I love that the  reality star looked chic in this sexy  curve hugging number and we're loving  the high pony on her  Kim's night out comes just ahead of that  baby number three confirmation that came  on Thursday and the new promo for  Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kim and  Kanye's new little girl is doing January  via surrogate her younger sisters Chloe  and Kylie Jenner are also expecting  babies early next year  I mean it's so exciting  [Music]  you